Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一个现在正在发生的激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊主办的“冲刺持续收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则同样适用于你。挑战赛中还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士——进行一对一咨询指导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），或查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详细信息发给你。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。节目主持人是玛丽安·特伦特博士。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。
Thank you for those of you who had been part of my world within the last application season so I am well aware that this week on the 17th of June is going to be the final date for letting courses know whether you are going to be accepting or declining your offer of a place and so you know come 2 p.m on that date if you haven't let your clinical courses know that you are accepting a place then they may well decide for you that you you don't want that place so you need to make sure that you have let people know via the clearinghouse website if you are indeed applying for the clinical psychology training courses and this will lead to complicated feelings for those who were on waiting lists so it might be that imminently after that date that you do manage to get a place because people
感谢在上一申请季中一直陪伴我的朋友们。我很清楚，本周6月17日将是通知各大院校你是否接受或拒绝录取通知的最后期限。因此你知道，在那个日期的下午2点，如果你还没有通知临床心理学课程院校你接受录取，那么他们很可能会替你做决定，认为你并不想要这个名额。所以，如果你确实申请了临床心理学培训课程，务必确保通过清算所（clearinghouse）网站将你的决定告知相关人员。这会给那些在候补名单（waiting list）上的人带来复杂的情感，因为在该日期之后不久，你可能确实会成功获得一个名额，因为有些人
have maybe been trying to to make up their mind which course to pick and by that date they will have needed to let the course know which one they are picking and which one they are not but of course there are only so many places to go around and so it might be that you are learning that you have not been successful in gaining a place this year but of course what we know is if you were offered a reserve list place if you were offered you know that opportunity then they are saying that you were of doctorate standard and they think you would have been a good fit for them and for their course and so there is much to celebrate there although of course I know that this will feel very very difficult you'll be very disappointed and if you weren't successful in getting interviews or perhaps if you did have interviews but you weren't successful in being offered either an outright
可能一直在纠结该选择哪门课程，而到了那个日期，他们必须告知院校自己的选择。当然，名额毕竟有限，所以你可能会得知自己今年的申请未能成功。不过，当然，我们知道如果你曾获得候补名单的名额，如果你曾获得那个机会，那就说明你达到了博士的标准，他们认为你很适合他们以及他们的课程，这非常值得庆幸。尽管我当然知道这会让你感觉非常非常艰难，你会感到非常失望。如果你甚至没有获得面试机会，或者也许你参加了面试，但最终没有直接获得
place or a reserveless place then it can feel a lot like rejection but actually I think it can be useful to reframe that and to think that they're just saying it's not yet it's a not yet from us but keep trying and it can be possible to get feedback about why you weren't successful so if you weren't successful at the um at the form stage there is often like a tick box um reason why you weren't successful um and that's sent out kind of automatically so that was when it was paper forms but um I would think that you're still able to get feedback about why even electronically from from lots of courses but I know even when I was applying some of the courses didn't have the capacity to offer feedback and so I think it's really it can be useful to know why because it otherwise it just
录取名额或候补名单名额，那感觉就会很像遭到拒绝。但实际上，我认为重新构建这种认知会很有用，把这看作是他们只是在说“目前还不行”，这是来自我们的“暂时不行”，但请继续坚持。而且，我们是有可能获得关于为什么不成功的反馈的。所以如果你在表格审核阶段不成功，通常会有一个勾选框说明你不成功的原因，这通常是自动发送的——那是纸质表格时代的做法。不过我想，通过电子方式，你依然可以从很多院校获得关于原因的反馈。但我知道，甚至在我申请的时候，有些院校也没有能力提供反馈。所以我觉得，知道原因真的很有用，否则它只会
feels you know deeply personal and not very fair. But knowing that, you know, for example, Birmingham turned me down on both of the times that I applied to them because they thought that my academic experience needed strengthening, then that makes you think, well, OK, all right, well, that gives me a clear direction to be able to focus myself towards and to strive for. Whereas if you're not getting that constructive feedback, then that can be difficult. let's think about what we can do to help you you know optimally prepare for the time between now and September when the course is open for business again so when you can start submitting your
让你觉得（这针对性）极其强烈且非常不公平。但了解了这一点之后，比如伯明翰大学在我两次申请时都拒绝了我，因为他们认为我的学术经验还需要加强，这就让你觉得，好吧，明白了，这为我提供了一个明确的方向，让我能够集中精力并为之努力。而如果你得不到这种建设性的反馈，那就会很困难。让我们想想，为了帮你为从现在到9月课程重新开放、可以开始提交申请表这段时间做好最佳准备，我们能做些什么……
application forms so for those of you who have listened to my compassionate Q&As, both during the application season and during the interview season, you'll be pleased to know that they're coming back. I've got some dates here for you. So I believe the courses will be opening on the 1st of September again. And so just forgive me flicking through my pages as I do this. The first one is currently scheduled for 7.30pm on Thursday, the 1st of September 2022. Usually I do them on Monday, but I thought I'd be there with you on that Thursday. Just to, you know know open the doors enthusiastically for you and then I think we've got some other dates I've penciled in as well we've gone for
所以，对于那些听过我在申请季和面试季的同理心问答（Compassionate Q&As）节目的听众，你们会高兴地听到它们回归了。我这里有一些日期要告诉大家。我想课程应该会在9月1日重新开放。请原谅我一边说一边翻看笔记。第一场目前计划于2022年9月1日星期四晚上7点30分举行。通常我会在周星期一做直播，但我想在那天周四和大家在一起。只是为了，你知道的，热情地为你们敞开大门。然后我想我们还有其他一些已经初步定下的日期，我们选择了
Monday the 10th of October at 7 30 p.m and there is a November one I'm sure I penciled a November one in but I can't find it but anyway there will be a November one coming. So you can pop those dates in your diary and know that I will be there for you to answer any questions that you might have about the application cycle as well. So I know it can feel a bit groundhog day, you know, with this relentless cycle, but I would really hope that by the time you submit your form, you know, in November, you might submit it before, you might be ready before. But for me, I wanted every second I could have to work on it I really I really you know when it was my time 2007 I was applying I spent as long as I could really intently focusing on giving my all to that form and making sure that every word counted every word mattered that's the approach that I took the year that I was successful and my forms were very very very different you know I applied three times and was successful the third time but my form at time three could not
10月10日星期一晚上7点30分，还有一个11月的场次。我确信我记下了11月的一个场次，但我找不到了。不过无论如何，11月还会有一场。所以你可以把这些日期记在日程表里，并且知道我会在那里陪伴你们，回答你们关于申请周期的任何问题。我知道这种无休止的循环可能会让人感觉像《土拨鼠之日》一样单调乏味，但我真的希望，当你11月提交表格时——也许你会提前提交，也许你会更早准备好。但对我而言，我希望拥有每一秒可以利用的时间来打磨它。我真的——当轮到我2007年申请的时候，我花了尽可能长的时间，极其专注地把全部心血倾注在那份表格上，确保每一个字都算数，每一个字都至关重要。那是我成功那一年所采取的方法。我的表格……真的、真的、真的很不一样。你知道，我申请了三次，在第三次才成功。但第三次时的表格，与
have been more different than at time one and at time two it wasn't a successful form and so I started again entirely with my form three and I didn't look at it at all until I was kind of almost finished in case I'd forgotten some golden nugget I hadn't I was just appalled with what I'd written but it demonstrated for me how much change I had undergone you know both personally and professionally and in my levels of confidence at being myself and the way that I think the way I talk about things and just my level of comprehension was vastly different by the time I was successful compared to my previous two attempts and so you know I would hope that your form also looks different if this is not your first rodeo you know if you've if you've been there before
第一次和第二次时相比，简直有着天壤之别。前两次的表格并不成功，所以我第三次时完全重新开始填写表格。直到我差不多快写完时，我才回头看之前的表格，生怕自己漏掉了什么金玉良言——其实并没有，我只是对之前写的东西感到震惊。但这向我证明了，与前两次尝试相比，到我成功时，我在个人、职业发展方面，以及做自己的自信程度上，甚至在理解力层面上，都经历了多么巨大的改变。因此，你知道的，如果这不是你的“初次登台”，如果你以前也经历过失败（因为那次并未成功），我希望你的表格这次看起来也会有所不同，
because that wasn't successful so it needs to be unless you know you did get interviews and you were offered places on reserve even then you, we want you to get across the line fully, you know, we don't want you to be having to wait till the bitter end where you might or might not get, you know, a reserveless place. We want you across the line in the first set of interviews, if possible. And that's not, you know you know in any way shape or form saying that reserveless places are less favorable but they certainly feel a little bit easier to swallow and a little bit you know oh god oh good there's less waiting around and the you know you know your outcome quicker so in terms of just having you have the kindest journey
因为之前的并未成功。所以它必须有所改变——除非，你知道的，你确实获得了面试并被列入了候补名单。即便如此，我们也希望你能彻底冲过终点线，你知道的，我们不希望你苦等到最后一刻，去碰运气看能不能拿到候补名额。如果可能的话，我们希望你在第一轮面试中就成功过关。这绝不是说候补名额不好，但直录的名额确实更容易让人接受，会让你觉得“哦谢天谢地，不用苦苦等待了”，能更快地知道结果。为了让你的这段旅程能更轻松一些，
I'd rather you had an outright place because it helps you make choices you know and helps you plan and prepare so that would be my preference for you but if you do get offered a reservist place then that is still obviously absolutely wonderful okay so yeah between now and september i think it can be useful to look at your gaps in your cv or certainly to look at your cv and see what gaps emerge um you know so when we're certainly working with clinical um then you need to you know be demonstrating that you've got some experience across the lifespan across the different areas that you will be working in as a trainee clinical psychologist so that would include children and young people that would include working age adults, that would include older adults, that would include intellectual disabilities. So those kind of four areas, it might include some physical health as well, it might involve
我更希望你直接获得录取名额，因为这有助于你做选择，有助于你进行规划和准备。所以这会是我对你的首选。但如果你确实获得了候补名额，那当然也绝对是非常棒的。好了，所以在现在到9月这段时间里，我觉得审视自己简历上的空白，或者对照简历看看有哪些不足，会很有用。因为当我们从事临床工作时，你需要证明自己拥有跨越全生命周期、跨越未来作为临床心理学实习生所需要涉足的不同领域的经验。这会包括儿童和青少年，包括工作年龄的成年人，包括老年人，还包括智力障碍人群。这大约是四个领域，可能还会包括一些躯体健康相关经验，可能涉及
some kind of neuro work, it might involve, you know, physical disabilities, or traumatic brain injuries, or, you know, might involve research you know you may maybe need to look at how many of those competencies you're able to tick off and if you are missing some then it might be that you can just give your mindful attention to trying to plug one of those gaps between now and mid-November because you know the wheels of certainly the NHS and the wheels of you know other organizations don't always turn without resistance and they don't always turn quickly and so if you can recognize those gaps in your CV now then by the time November comes you might well have started to you know to just chip away at any of those gaps or blocks to help you move towards
某种神经心理学工作，可能涉及身体残疾或创伤性脑损伤，或者可能涉及研究。你可能需要审视一下自己能够勾选其中多少项胜任能力。如果你有所欠缺，那么你或许可以集中精力，在现在到11月中旬之间努力填补其中一个空白。因为你知道，NHS（国民保健制度）以及其他机构的运转并不总是毫无阻力的，它们的运转也并不总是很快。所以，如果你现在就能识别出简历中的这些空白，那么等到11月到来时，你可能已经开始一点点攻克这些空白或阻碍，从而帮助你走向
a position where you are in you know where you're likely to be able to perform optimally on your form and to perform optimally at interview to give you the best chance of being able to achieve what you want, which is a place on this professional training scheme for becoming, maybe not becoming a clinical psychologist, but becoming a qualified psychologist or certainly a trainee psychologist at this stage let's just take a short break here and I will be back along very soon to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective is an encouraging read for anyone considering clinical training.
这样一个状态：你更有可能在表格填写中表现出色，在面试中表现出色，从而获得最大的机会来实现你的愿望——也就是在这个专业培训项目中获得一席之地，成为一名——也许不是成为临床心理学家，而是成为一名合格的心理学家，或者在这个阶段至少成为一名实习心理学家。让我们在这里稍作休息，我很快就会回来。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。充满了课程和经验，将帮助你获得资格。快来看看吧。它就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。《临床心理学家合集》对于任何考虑临床培训的人来说，都是一本令人鼓舞的读物。
Reading the stories of people who have followed their unique path into clinical training with ups and downs is immensely encouraging. Thank you Marianne for writing this book and to all who contributed to it. This book is a true blessing and I'm sure it can provide more clarity to anyone considering a career in clinical health and counseling psychology if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified Thank you. What can be useful is to make sure that you are getting quality supervision and guidance. And if you don't have that, or if you feel like you'd welcome some additional support and guidance, a bit more compassion, a bit more direction in certain areas that are key to becoming a successful aspiring psychologist, then do consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership. We get lovely reviews and people have said just that it's really really useful for them certainly people who've gained places on training this year
阅读那些带着起伏跟随自己独特的道路进入临床培训的人的故事，是极其令人鼓舞的。感谢玛丽安写了这本书，也感谢所有为此做出贡献的人。这本书真是个宝藏，我确信它能为任何考虑在临床健康和咨询心理学领域发展的人提供更多清晰的指引。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南，里面充满了帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。谢谢。有用的做法是确保你获得了高质量的督导和指导。如果你没有这些，或者如果你觉得你需要一些额外的支持和指导，需要更多同理心，在成为一名成功的有志心理学家的关键领域需要更多方向，那么请考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）。我们收到了很好的评价，人们也正是这么说的：这对他们真的非常非常有用。今年获得培训名额的人确实
said that they felt that the membership gave them everything they needed to to perform optimally at those interviews so if you feel that you want to really you know supercharge your chances supercharge your confidence then do consider checking out the aspiring psychologist membership but i will always do my best to provide free content for you if that's outside of your current affordability within this podcast and within my Q&As but if you really wanted some more focused and you know you get to talk back to me and I'll talk back to you it's a little less one-sided than a podcast if you wanted to be part of my world do check out the aspiring psychologist membership but if you are feeling disappointed come the 17th of June then you can lean into that you know you don't necessarily need to be cheering
说过，他们觉得会员计划提供了他们在面试中发挥出最佳水平所需的一切。所以，如果你觉得想要真正增强你的机会、增强你的信心，请务必考虑了解一下“有志心理学家会员计划”。但如果这超出了你目前的经济承受能力，我仍将尽我最大努力在本播客中以及我的问答环节中为你提供免费内容。不过，如果你真的想要更有针对性的内容，并且你可以与我对话，我也会与你对话——这比单向的播客要互动得多——如果你想成为我世界的一部分，请务必查看“有志心理学家会员计划”。但如果在6月17日到来时你感到失望，那么你可以去接纳这种情绪，你知道的，你不一定非得强颜欢笑，
yourself up you know this mattered and you had your hopes set on it and you know you're allowed to be sad you're allowed to lean into that, you don't need people to cheer you up but it's helpful if you have people that get it, that understand just how difficult this is you know because even when you do get training places you know it's not always an easy thing that you're saying you're going to do. So, you know, you may, for example, live in Edinburgh and be offered a place in London and you're prepared to pack up your bags and move your life for at least three years. That's not something that we do without thinking it through thoroughly. People are moving all over the country. Sometimes people are moving without, you know, their children, without their partners. And they're trying to,
这很重要，你对它寄予了厚望，你允许自己难过，你允许自己去感受这种情绪，你不需要别人来逗你开心。但如果你身边有能懂你的人，能理解这有多么困难的人，那会很有帮助。因为即使当你真正获得了培训名额，你知道的，这往往也不是一件轻松的差事。所以，比方说，你可能住在爱丁堡，却被伦敦的某个名额录取了，而你已经准备好收拾行囊，为了至少三年的时间搬迁生活。这不是一件不经过深思熟虑就能做出的决定。人们正在全国各地搬迁。有时候人们搬家时无法带上他们的孩子、他们的伴侣。他们试图，
you know, they're going to make it work by commuting and, you know, living, living perhaps in Airbnbs or, you know, rented accommodation for work weeks. And this isn't something that people are entering into lightly or, you know, for cheery kicks. This is because they are passionate about pursuing this career in psychology. So, you know, maybe when your time does come, you will get offered a place which causes less disruption to your life. But you might still have disruption to your life but you might still have disruption to your life you know you might purposely be choosing courses that are further away from where you're living now you might want
你知道的，他们通过通勤来维持生活，也许在工作日里住在 Airbnb 或租来的住所里。人们并非轻率地或为了好玩才踏入这一行的。这是因为他们对追求心理学事业充满热情。所以，也许当你的时刻真正到来时，你会被录取到一个对你生活干扰较小的名额。但你可能依然会面临生活的打乱，但你可能依然会面临生活的打乱，你知道的，你可能会故意选择距离你现在居住的地方更远的课程，你可能想要
a fresh start you might want to go and do something new and different or you might recognize that your best you know your best chance of being you know recruited by a course that is aligned to you is really far from where you live currently or that a particular course direction really appeals to you and so you are going to be moving you know countries within the UK or you know maybe from further afield as well and that is a consideration. It's a big change and it's difficult because you're having to put your life on hold. And so if you are in that position, then I'm just sending you so much warmth and compassion. And please do stay part of my world so that we can help further put that compassion into your situation but do bear
一个全新的开始，你可能想去做一些新鲜不同的事情。或者你可能会认识到，你被与你契合的课程录取的最大机会，其实离你目前的居住地非常遥远；或者某个特定的课程方向极大地吸引了你，所以你将要在英国境内跨地区搬迁，或者也许是从更远的地方搬来，这也是一个需要考虑的因素。这是一个巨大的改变，而且很艰难，因为你不得不将生活按下暂停键。因此，如果你正处于这种境地，我只想向你送去满满的温暖和同理心。请继续留在我的世界里，这样我们可以进一步将这种同理心融入你的处境中。但请务必记住
in mind the dates that I had given you for the upcoming Q&A sessions between September and November yeah if you would like to rate and review this podcast please do so on apple podcasts which you can do by clicking on the show scrolling right down below the trailer episode and you'll see the rate and review section there it will honestly just take you a moment but it would mean a great deal to me so thank you very much for listening and i will look forward to catching up with you very soon if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side to be on your way to being qualified
我给你的那些在9月至11月即将进行的问答环节的日期。是的，如果你想给这个播客评分和写评价，请在 Apple Podcasts 上进行，你只需点击节目、向下滚动到预告片剧集下方，就会看到那里的评分和评价板块。老实说，这只占用你一会儿时间，但对我有很大意义。非常感谢你的收听，我很期待很快与你交流。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这伴你左右，让这个播客成为你的指南，助你顺利获得资格。
it's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend
这里是玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜，我是一名实习心理健康从业者（psychological wellbeing practitioner）。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。它让我惊叹的是，通往这个职业的道路竟然有这么多，并没有成为它的“完美”方式。这让我充满信心：不，我没有做错，同时也减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐
this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会想把它放下。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。